[Music]
yeah yeah
celebrate it
[Music]
oh right
what's up you little crippled missiles
how y'all doing huh huh you little one
out arthropods dude what is that a worm
I don't even know what is an arthropod a
worm I don't know I don't know that's
sometimes we you got to start at man I
don't know I know very little that's
gonna be my new motto hey buddy you know
something I don't you know wish I did
you know knowledge is power knowledge is
pressure as well man having too much
knowledge as pressure you know not being
open to new ideas boy you get stranded
you know you can be between a rock and a
hard place and you just might be the
rock you ever think about that sometimes
you you find yourself between a rock and
a hard place
and you you're the rock so sometime you
got to soften up and open your brain up
to other people's ideas I'm gonna give
you an idea right here it is Monday
November 6th 2017 and we are living on
earth here in this galaxy and that's all
we know that's all I know today man
that's all I'm running on thank you guys
happy November some people still want to
think that uh you know that it's not
almost seasonal time we'll go to a CBS
ok go to a dang CBS or a rite-aid
Walgreen okay go to a dollop gin roll
and go to a 99-cent shop and see if you
don't you know what I'm saying see if
you don't see some accoutrement sup
there see if you don't see a special
turkey you know one of those um you know
a paper mache turkey kit you know or
some uh some of those little cans of
gravy see if you don't see extra gravy
at the ends of aisle stacks of K and
gravy see if you don't see them starting
to push all of that
that pumpkin pie bubblegum you know and
that uh you know dry giblet salad walnut
raspberry things you know what I'm
talking about
damn raisins see if you don't see if
they don't start peddling all of that
it's it's because it's winter time it's
the holidays man if somebody comes at
you this week they won't
I need downy bro it's the holidays all
right
the only thing I'm doing for the next 16
or 17 days is planning how I'm going to
eat my turkey am I gonna have it fried
am I gonna have it frizzled permed you
know how do you like your turkeys how do
you like your turkey pieces you want
that dark that white that longneck would
you like that turkey neck I used to have
a step uncle and he used to suck on a
turkey neck he'd get that long strand of
turkey neck meat put it in his mouth and
then just slowly pull it out of his
mouth and pretend it was a tongue he
would tell us it was a tongue when we
were children and it would look a little
bit like a tongue in fact him maybe it
wasn't even turkey neck it could have
been turkey tongue or some kind of
animal tongue and he was pretending it
was his tongue and he was wild and his
daddy was wild his daddy was named after
one of the what are those guys three
musketeers his daddy was mr. d'Artagnan
and his daddy would stay over and I
guess he was my step grandfather you
know and he was old man mr. d'Artagnan
was old and he would let us put lotion
on his legs at night in a non-sexual way
and it was pretty fun you know and
that's back when you know it was it was
rare that my brothers and sisters and I
got together and did anything and then
uh mr. d'Artagnan would let us put
lotion on his legs at night sometimes
and it was pretty fun I think just
because and it wasn't sexual man and I
know some people are like that's gross
you know that's you know y'all being
naughty with that old man you know where
he's being naughty with y'all it wasn't
that
okay I knew people that were out there
on new naughty makers you know I knew
people out there that were sounding
dirty horns in the distance you know and
people eat jacking back there behind the
birch trees and all of that you know and
you know doing dirty stuff down by the
big culverts and the end of the end of
the storm drains and everything and into
the recycling bin nice to have man needs
to spray out into the recyclers in our
neighborhood and they caught him
actually some a couple of dogs caught
him and then the police caught him but
but mr. dartie mwyn like that he just
old man you know obsessed of putting
lotion on constantly had lotion do you
couldn't I mean you can barely if you
tried to shake his hand your hand would
slip right off of his that's how I mean
that band was greased up and I think he
probably used other types of lubricants
random lubricants or anything around the
house you know
coconut oil thick water you know
neosporin anything
petroleum jelly kerosene you know he
just liked to have a little bit of shine
to him a little bit of shimmer he didn't
like that natural skin he didn't like
the I think he would have preferred
honestly having more of a snit of a
otter type body if he could have been an
otter but he was a man mr. d'Artagnan
and he I know some of the times when he
stayed by house he would let us kids put
lotion onto his legs he would put it
well he would put it on and let us rub
it in and you think that's crazy too but
until you've rubbed lotion into an old
man's knees it's not bad it's fun kind
of you know it's almost you know you're
you know you're trying to get all this
lotion into their into their skin and it
was pretty fun man but welcome to this
past weekend guys appreciate you guys
joining me got a lot of cool stuff I
guess it happened this week we had some
good callers I was actually gonna go to
Africa I was going to go to Africa and
it got cancelled I was supposed to go
perform for a sheik or a sheikh you know
shi shi kay listen to this so the other
day open my email I get an email there
days ago it says they want you in the
Seychelles which is off the coast of
Madagascar oh you thought it was just a
cartoon no it's a country you nut you
bag of damn dung jalapenos get the fire
out of your feces brother okay stay
natural it is a country Madagascar and
off the island of it there's a place
called the Seychelles and it is supposed
to be just beautiful so I get an email
in my inbox this is a neat thing about
being a in this business sometimes is
that I get an email in my inbox and it
says hey they want you in the Seychelles
they want you how a Saudi prince or a a
shake a-shake wants you to come and
perform they said and here's how it was
gonna be I would fly there it's 24 hours
of flying right so I'd fly there I could
stay for two or three nights at the
resort you're also at a resort that's
right there
and then you go to the special event
that's going on for the Sheik you
perform for the audience and then you
leave you perform behind a plastic-like
you know you ever go to like you ever be
in a neighborhood a scary neighborhood
or any neighborhood and you go to get a
pay for your gasoline at night and the
man is in there in a little cage and at
first you think he's sick you know he
has you know they quarantine him he's
got yellow pox or you know he's got cat
fever or whatever cat scratch fever or
whatever they call it you know they keep
them inside of the cage and you got to
slide things to him and that drawer slot
I'm a you know a TV dinner or whatever
you know but that's what I mean anyway
actually those men are in there for
safety and they're behind a plastic
thing well that's the kind of thing you
perform for behind the for the Sheik so
his audience is all out there you're in
this you know in this I'll guess almost
a human aquarium you do your act and you
leave you never get to meet anybody at
the party blah blah blah or the event
that's what I heard that's what the
that's what what the offer was to me
right they said we'll pay you this
amount of money you got to go there I
said and I could bring a friend but I
was like it was economy it was regular
you know regular seating and I'm not
fancy pants I'll sit in regular seating
I'll sit by the window you know if I
have my preference but I said look man
I'm fine
24 hours to get there was three flights
Dubai Frankfurt so I'm thinking I'll go
first class so I throw that back I said
look only way I'm going is if I can go
first class you know and I don't need to
take a friend I asked two friends nobody
can go so next thing you know they come
back and they say okay first class boom
next thing you know tomorrow I'm
supposed to be heading to Africa zones
in Africa to go over there and and
perform for the Sheikh and then hang out
for two nights or three nights at this
resort and instead I get an email last
night literally 11:40 p.m. said the
Sheikh something else came up you know
he's gonna be shaken I'll shake down
Street somewhere else and he can't be
there so I don't get to go to Africa now
so anyway that's one of the trials and
tribulations that come sometime in this
business you know you think even go back
to the motherland or the fatherland you
know I'm not sure which one it is I know
the motherland is Africa the fatherland
I'm guessing is what Italy you know
Greece probably I'm if you ever had a
Greece a grecian around you you know but
um but they can be kind of fatherly
sometimes you know so anyhow man that
was a little bit of a letdown from my
week what else is going on dude hmm I
don't know I've been dealing with like
some relationship type stuff you know
you know kind of like this girl and I
just you know I just got so much fear
when it comes to that kind of stuff it's
so hard for me to like move forward in
relationships and you know commit to
those sort of environments I mean it's
just oh it's almost like impossible it's
almost impossible for me to even like
make that connection and like believe
that it's I don't know if this is gonna
make sense but in my but in my in my and
my brain like believe that it's gonna
work out I guess I don't know I don't
know man
just really hard for me to commit you
know and I don't even think it's not
that I don't want to I think it's just
that it's like I get to these walls
where I can sigh God don't even know how
to you know just even just you know the
idea of having a girlfriend just makes
me just panicked you know it's just like
you know in a some of it could come from
you know growing up and just having it
tough you know not a strong connection
with my mother that connection drove me
bananas or whatever you know I don't
know you know I'm figuring some of that
out now but but yeah just you know and I
had an instance I was talking with this
girl and you know she could she wasn't
feeling that good about herself and I
know all she wanted me to do was say oh
you know you're you you're pretty you
know she was feeling bad about her looks
you know and and I couldn't say it man
like I couldn't I know that's what she
wanted all she wanted was just me she
wasn't fishing for a compliment you know
but I know I could just tell that it
would have made her feel good if I'd
have said you know oh you know look I
think you know I think you're very
pretty you know and it was easy I knew I
knew that's what my job was as a human
at that moment but I just couldn't it
was like I was so scared that if I like
let this person if I'm if I hope to make
this person feel good that that they
would they would know that then I would
be responsible for making them feel good
again and it's like maybe I didn't have
enough I wasn't real I like I couldn't I
didn't know if I could do that you know
it's almost like I didn't trust myself
enough to to make myself the type of
person who would make them feel good you
know again I don't know if that makes
sense or not I'm trying to trying to get
through some of my thoughts here with
you guys right now at the moment I guess
has maybe wild I don't know but yeah I
just I just couldn't do it I was just
like well if I let her know that I care
right now but saying this then then I'm
gonna actually have to care you know and
I'm gonna
actually start committing myself to
caring and that that's gonna be really
scary for me because for most of my life
I've probably just been used to caring
for myself and not even in like an
egomaniac type way just in like a
survival type of way I think you know
like I was just so probably afraid that
nobody else was caring about me that I
had to care so much about me you know
and letting some of that go and actually
caring about someone else it's just a
slippery slope just a slippery slope so
I don't that's some of the personal
stuff I guess has been going on oh I
need to make this announcement I need if
you live in Los Angeles or I have a
friend that does and you are interested
in possibly working as a producer for
this past weekend drop me an email or
hit me up on the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three or
drop me an email Theo von at mac.com I
need some help so things are happening
here or you know we're getting we're
building up steam and I need some help
so you know that's one thing that I kind
of is kind of like a thought that's been
resonating in my mind this week was the
two things that I need to do or I need
to work hard and I need to ask for help
when I need it and those are two things
that have often been hard for me to do
you know I've always been a worker but
to work hard sometimes it can I can get
sidetracked and ask for help I've always
had a tough time with that but not today
not tonight you know not today whatever
day it is whenever you watch this it's
Sunday evening for me November 5th and
it's Monday November 6 for this episode
of this past weekend so that's what's
going on guys you know we got some great
callers I'm gonna hit those in a second
I also want to let you know that you can
check out the patreon.com slash Theo von
4 extended footage from this week I also
just put up a video on there I got some
new headshots and pictures taken coz
here in Hollywood you got to have new
pictures of yourself you got a pictures
of your face and of your you know your
eyes and you know
your mouth and your hair and you have
pictures of you and I've been using this
picture that looks like I work at a like
at a Chase Bank you know like a young
buck that works at a Chase Bank
you know like in hunt like in like in
Birmingham Alabama and it's like kind of
like a young manager and might be you
know could possibly be bisexual those
are some of the headshots that I've been
using and they aren't serving me anymore
because I do not look like that right
now so the the roles that I've been
getting to go audition on our 4 young
possibly closeted bankers I'm just
joking but also I've been going on roles
for you know generals and an army or
things where a knight and then I get
there and they're like dude you aren't
gonna be the general you're gonna be the
guy peeling potatoes you know so I've
been having a you know I got some new
headshots so those are the types of
things I'll be putting up on the patreon
and plus extended footage off from
today's episode of new extent emotive
extended footage every other week but
you can check that out patreon common
and I want to thank you to all the
patreon supporters they've helped us to
get this new camera we got some new
lighting coming in and they're gonna
help us to get to this this producer
that we have as well this new producer
and we got our our charter sponsor and
that is gray block pizza if you're in
Los Angeles hit up that gray block dude
they got it I had some this week man and
if I were to pick my teeth right now who
taste boy taste taste taste taste
that's great block pizza and we're happy
to have them on board oh let me tell you
this man I um I watched that by Spang
Michael by Spang first George st. Pierre
fight and I'm not you know I saw I
remember first fight I ever saw you know
oh this Irish fellow named Milford King
through a senior citizen into a ditch
fire when I was young and that man came
back at him a senior citizen mr. Pulido
he got lit up on fire
and that man stormed back at him he
thought he was dead he does gonna die
but that man came out that ditch with
flames piggybacking on his skin and on
his flannels and on the suspenders he
had suspenders you know the last thing
you want to have home and your clothes
are on fire is suspenders because that
just means that it's harder to get all
your clothes off and I watch this old
man just burn and just were just coming
right at him
just like a small senior citizen Italian
flaming cyclone coming right at big
Milford king with that a man had 9-inch
chest hair dude that guy could cornrow
his chest hair man and sometime he let
it he them he would let some of the
black girls cornrow his chest hair nice
and you'd think that's a line that's not
even a lie but that's one of the first
fights I saw but I got to watch some of
these fights man I went watch two fights
the other night and that by spring Saint
Pierre was cook wild did Saint Pierre I
mean that man the first of all he might
be French he might be Canadian
you know you don't even know dude I mean
he he's so proper he only he kind of
looked like Lance Armstrong if Lance
Armstrong got ahold of some actually
good drugs you know not that [ __ ] that
was just making him by cycle you know
because anybody could dam by cycle dude
I got a seven-year-old niece you know
that's out there competing locally in
cycling you know but to get out there
and be UFC and you know excuse me you
got to really be into it you know and
you got to have that high class stuff
going on inside of your body but st.
Pierre man he really got out there and
the way he finished off the fight at the
end and was such a was so like just
kindred about it afterwards you know
he's respectful of the sport respectful
of the audience and and so it was by
spaying man he said the same stuff he
said you know that man's got a hell of a
squeeze on him he squeezed me out and by
spaying wild dude he got blacked out he
didn't even tap out because you could
tap your arm on the carpet if you don't
want to fight anymore you can tap your
arm on the carpet you know it's probably
got an old folks home if you
too many pills that they pilling you up
you just give that beat down and they
you know they stop the presses on that
morphine drip err on their Moxie's you
know they keep pop pop off their Moxa's
but man he just said Nam it's gonna go
on all the way I'm gonna keep fighting
until I'm unconscious man that was that
was incredible to see dude because I
will tap out before the fight starts you
know what I'm saying dude I will tap out
if we're supposed to fight tomorrow dude
I'll tap out tonight before dessert you
know I'm saying icicle I'll order two
scoops ice cream and [ __ ] tap out
right here at the dinner table so that
was impressive man just to see men to go
to those depths you know to see men go
that deep and get into their brains that
much and thank you guys for joining me
this time on this past weekend I'm gonna
hit uh a call right here we had some
callers they hit the hotline the hotline
is nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three we had some callers that
hit the hotline and we're talking about
what's real what feels real to people
and then we had a couple other calls
that came I don't want to get to some of
them but I appreciate you guys I
appreciate you guys being here with me
and let's get into this call right here
here we go what's up to you it's Devon
calling again from Tampa
what's up Devon thank you for calling
from Tampa dude Tampa if you get down
there to Ybor City I remember I was down
there and they had a lot of men it was
being gentrified the downtown there you
bore city or you bore ybo are you bar
er was being gentrified and also
gentrified by predominantly gaygent
djent djent Raymond so it was wild
because you had this neighborhood that
was kind of thuggish but also there was
a lot of you know I'm a sexual man
running around you know and and no
offense if you're a homosexual man I
might be homosexual when I get older you
know some night don't take that out of
my cards until you know until I played
them all you know I'm saying don't take
that out of my deck and don't judge me
until I played them all but there was
got luck there was so you had this wild
mix down there of thugs and men that was
trying to catch that D you know
you know not all I'm trying to catch up
at least trying to catch a hug or look
you in the eyes for a long time then
then that's natural during a
conversation and I got out there and and
I kept having these dreams when I was
living there while I was staying there
for a week that I was getting jacked you
know cuz I had a lot of thugs and
gangbangers and then I was getting
jacked by gay gangbangers you know I
kept having this dream that a dude would
run up behind me and be like give me all
your money and let me suck on your dick
for a second you know and I kept having
that dream and then the guy made me
actually he took my wallet he made me
jerk off into my own wallet and took my
wallet so that's how that dream ended up
but anyhow that's uh that's some of the
stuff that I was uh that I went through
whenever I was um you know being down
there by Tampa but uh let's go on Devon
thank you for calling so I'm calling you
again [ __ ] taking them all again on
that last one and that's fine you know I
know sometimes if people hit the hotline
it'd give me a little nerve-wracking
just leaving a voicemail not known you
know if it's going into the ether or
what so I appreciate that homework I
wanted to maybe talk about what's real
as you said last episode you know I was
in Tallahassee last weekend with my
friends and it got me thinking of you
know what's real and just what's
important to me because you know we were
just sitting on the couch doing whatever
and you know just talking now doing
whatever sometimes can be drugs or it
can be you know rare you know I guess if
you could just be doing nothing also
nothing or drugs let's hear more I think
that that's that's what's real and
that's probably the only thing that's
real right now you know you just have so
many opinions on complete opposite sides
with each other and and you know both
sides you know politically or just
whatever just seemed to be so ridiculous
these days I can't even find myself
having opinions anymore you know oh
that's interesting yeah it's like it's
is it even worth having an opinion
anymore it's almost kind of nice it's
almost like nobody wants to really hear
anybody's opinion that much anymore you
know especially if your opinion has to
be right you know if you have to be
right
you know oh oh you know it all do you
guy Wow
well I'll be darned yeah now yeah it's
tough it is it's almost exhausting even
to have opinions that's interesting man
appreciate you sharing that thought
let's hear the end of this call no so so
what me and my friends I think we tend
to do and you know value humor so much
just because you know we just really sit
back in and observe and just really make
fun of it all and that's a good thing to
do man you know there's a lot of good
making fun of it all
now the problem I noticed out here in
Los Angeles is a lot of them making fun
of it all is it's only it's so one-sided
I mean you know you can't really be
universal these days in even and I feel
like in humor well in humor you can try
but it's tough man you know it's very
it's very hard for people these days to
see other people's perspectives or to
really want to try to you know and
that's really tough for a lot of people
but yeah is it worth even having
opinions maybe it's not maybe it's a
time when we can take a break from
having some strong opinions you know and
just get into what makes us feel good
but yeah spending time with your friends
that is pretty real man you know a buddy
of mine he's a musician you know he does
music and um he can do the piano and he
can do I think different types of
instruments I have to ask him but he
invited me over to watch the fights and
at first I was like you know I don't
know if I'm gonna go and it didn't have
anything to do it my friend it just had
to do it me what do I want to do what do
I want to get out of my you know I'm
comfortable just and then I said you
know what I'm just gonna go I'm just
gonna go and the second I get somewhere
I have a good time you know usually
unless it's an uncomfortable environment
you know you know like a free free lance
gun range or a damn you know a birthday
party for a one-year-old that [ __ ] is
ridiculous dude if I'm one and you see
somebody throw me a birthday party dude
bro you could you could throw darts at
everybody at that thing
strong darts pointy ones big ones ones
you have to throw with two hands because
I don't want somebody throw me a damn
birthday party when I'm one weird story
though I did go to a birthday party for
one year
before I had this point of view at a
Perry Farrell's house who was a lead
singer Jane's Addiction and that was um
that was interesting but thank you for
that call man
thank you for that call I don't even
know what my train of thought was right
there what are we thinking about let's
hear a little bit more here we go hey
Theo what's going on man Pete from
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania Pete what's up
brother how you feeling you feeling good
thank you for calling let's hear some
more
I love the podcast dude it's awesome
very real you know you seem like a super
cool guy and I was just wondering about
the Internet in general and Internet
addiction because I feel like my default
state is to go home and I just get on
the computer I get on the internet and
I'm so sick of it it's just like a
default you know I'm not approving I got
so many things I want to do and you know
I want to talk to it go out talk to
people you know go learn the guitar
you're trained yeah you know it's funny
man I found myself recently doing that
on just with my phone I find I noticed
two things one I'll go to my phone and
then two I will I will
you know there's a couple of specific
things that I'll get on you know
instagrams or Twitter's you know or
texting and the most frustrating part is
the new iPhone update or whatever dude
that makes everything takes an extra
five seconds cuz it's slow you know it's
slow it's not working accurate you know
it's like my phone gots damn you know
mental disorder you know it's almost
like asking a dumb friend for something
every time you want to use it you know
it's like it's got to check its pockets
every time I ask him you know to borrow
every time I asked his phone to borrow a
dollar it's got to check its pockets or
you should just hit me with that book
but yeah I feel you man it's um it is
it's a crazy addiction let's hear a few
more of your thoughts on this but it's
hard to find the time to do anything if
all you do you know from working
you own the computer so I'm thinking a
totally getting rid of it but uh yeah
let me know maybe I'll throw it out the
window or something well look man is
that that's a real thing man you know
but that's a great if you throw it out
the window can you man
even the feeling I get when I don't have
my phone when I'm not sure where it is
it's unbelievable and it's crazy to
think that other things are illegal but
that having a [ __ ] but a phone is not
it's not Dean like an addictive like you
can't have cocaine cook because it's
addictive because it's bad for you but a
phone we can have it you know this is
just there's so much business tied to it
there's no way they would ever keep it
away you know and I and we would
probably be uproarious a lot of us would
be at first but I bet man two weeks
after being you know separated from
those things we would go back to I mean
that's the thing young people these kids
that they don't have any idea what it
was lying to does be a person you know
to use your imagination every time you
wanted to think of something or to see
something like that's the number one
thing I feel like we're going to be that
we're killing off is our imagination
like how his imagination supposed to
survive you know through time like
genetically in the face of technology I
don't see how it can I mean I was
talking to my niece you know and she's
seven or eight hell she might be nine
dude you know I'm kind of a mid-range
uncle and I wonder I was asking her
about I said use your imagination she's
like what do you what is that she's like
is that on the phone and it just blew my
mind she thought it was an app I thought
it was an app you know and that's it's
just like then what when an imagination
is dead man were locked we're locked
you know we're locked into advancement
that's based only
and it would seem like in hardware then
you know only in what is tangible you
know very tangible like you know I don't
want to say just in technology but I
don't know imagination used to be the
thing that I mean that was the thing
that kept me a lot of the most was that
I could escape my reality by having an
imagination and I just worried that if
kids don't have that in the future then
what is that if that doesn't evolve with
us as humans and what does it look like
you know what does it look like when
there's no imagination
when the only thing you are able to see
is only what's in front of you and that
when you go look inside your brain to
create something for yourself you're
unable to you know it's that's this
bizarre that's bizarre you know and I
yeah it's like how like at what level of
a phone is it still helpful to us you
know I don't find it that helpful you
know but then with that said I'll be
blasting out a link to this you know
I'll be posting something from this on
Instagram or Twitter or Facebook you
know so it's like certainly of use but
is it is it as addictive as a drug
everyone's addicted to the phone
addicted but then where there are other
things people were addicted to when they
first came out shoes you know spitting
on somebody dude I bet a long time ago
people were like no I would never spit
on somebody and then somebody spit on
somebody and somebody's like oh [ __ ]
yeah I'm spitting on somebody you know
or the first person that showed up with
shoes I'm strawberries like well [ __ ]
you know Constance is afraid of her feet
on the earth what a nutcase you know she
likes to you know she she you know she
likes to be upstairs but only like a
half inch upstairs you know and
Constance has on shoes but then now
Constance was a damn Constance Kista
door you know she was a pioneer because
everybody have shoes on you know we're
the first person to grow their eyebrows
out you know because if you look at a
lot of pictures and stuff
cave drawings and all that hieroglyphics
a lot of people they don't have eyebrows
they don't they don't put eyebrows on
people so I know it's not there's not a
lot of science out there to back it up
but I I don't think eyebrows were always
the most popular you know you know
facial follicle haberdashery going on
you know I mean they're really just
mustaches for your eyes that's all they
are and I think there was probably
somebody came along you know that first
day a guy had been living out on his own
for a little bit you know maybe ate some
plants that made him feel kind of you
know erotic and he got wild and he came
in with that good good you know and
that's all and that's how I think that
you know having eyebrows really took
over but some dude you know got shroom
doubt and you know for probably like a
month
I mean shroom doubt you know what I'm
saying man where he was just had the
rings of Saturn around his neck every
time he opened his eyes you know what
I'm saying
I'm talking about where you know he
might have seen the Mars rover landing
on his cheek because I do was living and
out of space you know I'm saying he
might have woke up with a Lance
Armstrong taste in his mouth cuz that
dude had that galactic breath you know
what I'm saying shroom doubt and then he
said you know I'm gonna grow my eyebrows
out and i'ma live a little I'm I have
mustaches above my eyes cuz I'll be
damned if each one of my optical circles
ain't gonna be [ __ ] Burt Reynolds
so you know that but I agree it's
addictive let's hear more let's hear
another call here Bo it's Bo I'm high
again damn it but um okay we got Bo he's
high again
didn't know you were high the first time
thank you for calling Bo you asked what
was real and I took a few days and I
thought about it and I think it's
family and friendships and it doesn't
necessarily have to be the people you
were raised by or the people that are
around you right now but it's the people
that you can just [ __ ] up so bad and
they still love you okay so that's
what's real is people you know family
and friendship and we had the same thing
at Devon called in about and and also
that people you can [ __ ] up and they'll
just forgive you no matter what and I'm
guessing those are the people that are
closest to you so that's kind of a way
to reframe them yeah I mean that is
pretty real you know I guess I see you
know mothers that when their sons get
convicted a murderer now they got
snapped because women are doing most of
the murdering or when their daughters
get you know convicted of you know
conspiring to you know derail an
election or whatever you know or their
sons do that you you know that the
mother is forgiving you know that the
mother is forgiving and I've always
wondered why how that's capable and I
think it's just probably that some of
that familial some that's something
that's beyond beyond calcula calculable
yeah that's that can't really be
quantified and that's that connection
between strong friends or strong family
let's hear more at times whenever you
don't even love yourself I think that is
the only thing that's real maybe not the
only thing that's probably you know I
don't know everything but to me I don't
know I'm kind of losing track of where
I'm going right now
because I just smoked a DAB and I'm
pretty high okay well I mean it there
you go
you know there you go look I appreciate
the honesty Heat were high when you
called a different time and you were
having you called this time man but I
respect that did that's brave to be high
and
call in that's brave man that's cool I
respect that dude for you to have that
you know because when I would get high
I'd be afraid to do anything man I'd be
afraid to do anything except try to
touch a little bit of crotch on it you
know around a local crotch you know or
maybe and even that sometime I be scared
you know
you ever have a girl come over and you
real high and they start looking like a
gremlin or something and you start being
afraid they're gonna suck all the blood
out of your body but yeah I appreciate
that call it reminds me man I saw Buzz
Aldrin this week I saw Buzz Aldrin if
you're not for me with Buzz Aldrin he is
a human man who was on the moon think
about the moon go outside look at the
moon guess who's been up there Buzz
Aldrin I met Buzz Aldrin dude I shook
his hand dude I shook his damn moon Paul
that's what I call it and it was
beautiful dude and it was truly
beautiful and Buzz Aldrin you know he
almost you almost get a buzz off a Buzz
Aldrin you know because some people you
get high off them you get around them
you get that hit you know you just you
get that hit off of their vibe and next
thing you know what I'm saying you
you're a living Thanksgiving you know
you got that energy going through you
you know you got them turkeys clucking
down in your duckets you know what I'm
saying and that's what happened with
Buzz Aldrin he gives you that vibe and
so then as soon as I got home I went and
read up all about the moon
you know and the moon is basically just
this little I mean that's just Earth's a
little side piece you know and this is a
unique fact about the when Buzz and Neil
landed on the moon they place the
American flag right they put it in the
ground very a stoic moment you know
we're very exciting America first we got
here and then they got back in the
shuttle and they press whatever buttons
closed everything up shut down shop
closed the moonroof at that point and
took off back to earth but whenever they
press the thrusters or whatever the
propulsion from the Jets to get them
back off of the moon surface knock down
the flag
so literally as they're flying they're
looking out the window and the [ __ ]
flag fell down and they're like wow [ __ ]
and that's it and they couldn't go back
there's no way to turn around so if you
want to know sometime what it's like to
just live in that you know like you know
sometimes everything's not perfect not
even for Buzz Aldrin or Neil Armstrong
sometimes you go to the moon and you
have a plan of how it's going to be and
it's not and I'll be honest that's how I
felt starting the podcast today dude I
didn't have a [ __ ] plan but sometimes
you don't have a plan you got to go
anyway you know so that's what we're
doing but I met Buzz Aldrin dude and I
remember meeting him and will he
remember meeting me I doubt that let's
hear another call what's up man I called
him last week there's things going on we
have a family friend in our community in
Indian community and the student has a
he's a millionaire he owns a bunch of
businesses okay have a family friend
it's an Indian community Native American
Indian it sounds like and he owns a
bunch of businesses she have a
successful Native American man who lives
in your community let's take it forward
and he's really good and he's really
good like financially give a family kid
wife and now for some reason last year
he decided to like hook up with one of
my friends sister whoo that's a wild
move cuz you sound like a young buck and
so now you got a financially secure
Native American gentleman dating your
friends sister let's hear more and he
did that and he started smoking crack
okay double up and a bunch of random
stuff happening and you know he just got
out of jail from staying there for one
year and um he left jail and now we're
we live in Louisville and no one comment
it's kind of a rich neighborhood no he
had 26 guns cannon or in common house
which is a millionaire's house and they
found crack pipes with the
some kind of drug residue um guessing
that drug residue is crack brother
onward I don't sounds really stupid but
what kind of person really does that to
themself if they have everything going
for them it kinda reminds me the Harvey
Weinstein issues but I don't know how
that I mean I'll tell what kind of mean
this is going to be Annie this is gonna
be an educated guess for me what kind of
person does that an addict you know this
man is probably an addict you know and
you have to look at this man is probably
ill you know the man obviously if
there's drugs there he's buying guns
probably a lot of paranoia
sounds like comes with a lot of that
crack use I've heard I don't know so
that's me you know guesstimating but if
you own that crack dude they don't call
it you know they don't call it repair
you know they call it crack you know I'm
saying it's not putting um it's not
increasing the foundation they don't
call it caulk eating out there smoking
caulk you out there smoking crack
because crack will whack you out crack
will put some some chinks in your armor
you know crack will break it down
literally you know you go in mean crack
will turn you into a San Andreas Fault
person that's what crack does man and so
that's why that's the answer to your
question these other things he's doing
sound like side dark side effects of
crack of drug use
you know he's chasing younger woman I
mean you know the chasing younger women
ain't nothing can that can happen you
know this there's some gin this is
something in a man were you there's you
can't always kill that off you can't
even when you get married and fall in
love you sometimes can't escape that you
know that desire you know to be want to
be sexual or have to do sex with
something young or something you know
that's more closer to you know the
younger side of life and the adult side
and I don't mean that in a nice sort of
pedophilia type of way but you know it
you might be attracted to a younger lady
a woman you know so but yeah that's an
addict that's your question who would do
that
you know and I don't know if you're
calling us to kind of tattle on this
dude or what and it's okay I mean I
guess you just
you know in a lot that's addiction and
it's the same thing with Harvey
Weinstein he got addicted to whatever
was going on you know sure he had some
dirty behaviors and he you know was
living in you know I mean this dude was
breakdance and on the you know on the
you know this dude was breakdancing on
the on the you know on the dance floor
of sin he's out there just you know this
dude was probably double-jointed in his
day cuz he's out there straight-up
cop twerking you know and doing the dark
arts and you know imposing his will on
two women who did not want his will
Minoo was what he's been accused of and
and that's but after a while you there's
a sickness there you get used to
whatever you you know you get used to it
and it's addiction and at some points
you also do you have to have some
empathy you know it's also it's sick to
see somebody do something but it's also
it's also it's also sad to see them be
sick
you know and I think that's probably
what you got in a neighborhood man you
got a crack artist around you you know
so if you want to you know lace his pipe
with a little bit of caulk
now you talking business so I think
that's what you should look into brother
but god bless you thank you for calling
all right guys we're gonna get to some
more calls in just a moment but before
we do I want to have Ari Maness has just
arrived and we're gonna have him in
studio here in just a second I just want
to get a catch up with what's going on
in his in his weird world so we'll be
right back with Ari menace this past
weekend yeah man maybe having him on as
a sidekick for like segment might be a
good idea because it is important for us
to have you you know it feels good but
it feels like it's often you I think
that's why a lot of people open up the
way that they do they just want you well
I don't think that's what they want but
it seems like you know they don't want
me well what did the gentleman say side
he said he wanted me just in a little
baby in dose baby peace micro dosing
microdose mm yeah want to dab they don't
want to join sometimes that's how it
starts yeah sometimes it starts with the
dab and then they go for the joint later
that's true and that could happen man
yeah but I want to say I'm happy to have
you in today man thank you for coming by
thanks for having me it's always good to
be here in the Theo von Studio yeah
that's already Maness guys is joining us
today we've had Ariane man I mean I
haven't been on probably in four or five
weeks yeah and last I checked you had
taken a girl your you were the
girlfriend you guys had just visited a I
don't want to call it didn't seem like a
honeymoon getaway but a weekend trip
down to the you know down of those
vaginal swap meets down there in Mexico
down to the prostitution houses
yeah the brothel and Tijuana that was a
fun night
but since then we have unfortunately
broken up me and the girlfriend oh
really
yeah okay and what was it cause of that
do you feel like I feel like this might
be a long boring story
but I'll tell you it okay I know what
you think but I loaned her some money to
fix her car ooh you know I don't make a
lot of money right by the way I'm not
rolling by any means but she needed a
car and I didn't want to give rides to
work I got over that after a day so we
need to get your car fixed okay so I
loaned her almost $700 right this was a
few weeks ago the first of the month
comes around mm-hmm I send her a text
because I'm paying the rent that we both
live in the rent into our apartment
mm-hmm and I said hey just checking in
on that money because I'm paying the
rent right now so I'm just seeing if you
had it she said I don't have it yet and
I said okay for sure she said are you
mad I said no I'm just really broke okay
and she said well you should consider
getting a second job Wow
and do you agree with her I mean the
thing is first off if I want a second
job or not that's up to me right but
secondly maybe I wouldn't need a second
job if you give me the money back that
you owe me yeah so it kind of flip this
switch in my head where I was like what
how like where do you get the gall yeah
the nerve to tell me to get a second job
when you owe me $700 yeah and gall a lot
of senior citizens say gall mugger
movies could I use the gall correctly
Oh God seniors used to use that and
almost that words dying off so I'm glad
literally dying off and both our
grandparents I'm bringing it back here
yeah I'm glad here to come back but I'm
saying so and so that flip the switch in
your head yes it just pissed me off you
know that she would have the nerve to
say that to me when she owes me money so
we started fighting of course back and
forth and then you have a job she has a
full-time job
9:00 to 5:00 okay I'm over in Culver
City okay maybe I shouldn't say that
over in Los Angeles and so I ended up
breaking up with her and she came home
and we cried and I think she realized
that she messed up in this situation and
she said she wouldn't do it again but we
just fight all the time
I mean I've talked about a few fights
just on this podcast yeah did you feel
like you were trying to get out of this
anyway and this was just that
opportunity maybe maybe a little bit cuz
I have talked about it before but in the
moment I wasn't thinking misses my out I
was thinking this is [ __ ] I'm ending
this so we broke up and it's been 2 or 3
days now and I miss her and when it hits
about midnight are you masturbating to
or thoughts of her no I've been using
write the regular porno okay seen her
like no not old pictures or anything
like that or sex tapes that we've home
videos we've recorded you guys did all
that yeah I got all that saved all that
yeah I'm not saying I'm gonna keep it
forever I may or may not I feel like
that's up to me I think we both agreed
to doing it therefore unless she asked
me to delete it I think I have the right
to keep it we're both adults who's on
the tape me and her yeah you are to
remember that day yeah yeah I'm not I
don't I definitely don't want to release
it yeah well I wouldn't release it I
mean who's gonna buy you know 20 guys at
the Comedy Store you know I'm saying
who's gonna I think actually maybe if
you know so I think more people are
releasing not for me for her she's a
she's an attractive young
oh that's she's out of my league which
brings me to my next thing that I was
going to say is I miss her
and do you feel like you made too big of
an issue about the money well to me it
wasn't the money it was it was thought
yeah I don't mind loaning her money I
trust her that she'd pay me back and and
a money is money but it was kind of just
the way she treated me after owing me
money okay so you lend her the money
with the stipulation she was gonna pay
you back mm-hmm was there a timeline or
how soon no just as soon as she could
but then it was just the fact that she
was telling me I should get a second job
right I should quit complaining it's
like you were you complaining a lot
about the money no it was at one time
one the first of the month when rent was
due how long after you launder the money
did she was that text exchange week
maybe a week after that yeah was a week
later probably not gonna have the money
right but I wasn't making a big deal of
it right I wasn't saying where's my
money I just said hey I'm paying the
rent do you by chance I see the money so
really just kind of also remind her to
keep it fresh yeah yeah fresh but my
question for you is I miss her right now
but we were fighting all the time back
and forth off and on should I take her
back is she willing to come back yeah
are you willing to excuse the 700 all
her payment yeah it's not the money
thing it was just kind of right what's
gonna change
exactly I don't know do you love her I
love her well you know I don't know
that's a tough one man it's a tough one
when there's love involved there there's
money involved there's obviously some
loneliness it seems like you're probably
you seem a little lonely ah yeah not a
lot but some sure as your sexual di me
you're out there deviant number one I
tried going to the brothel this last
weekend to try and make myself feel
better
did you maybe for about 10 minutes you
went all the way down to Mexico for ten
minutes I went to my I was doing shows
anyway but yeah you do shows in Mexico
in San Diego okay so then you went into
another country and then after that ten
minutes for some type of a sex exchange
possibly okay I mean look it's okay I'm
just saying you know let's don't be like
I'm going through hard times yeah let's
just don't say you don't trust me you're
judging me
I just want to get the facts straight
like so you're wandering I don't want to
be like oh I was wandering around and
just yes I went to the Hong Kong okay
with a friend and the Hong Kong is the
for those you got it on the Hong Kong is
the sexual establishment the
distribution center in Mexico if the
legal brothel illegal brothel my man
Tijuana
ok legal legal out yeah and I went there
to try and make myself feel better
did you purchase a lady I purchased some
service I may have yeah it's fine yeah I
did okay yeah I did and did you feel
better no you know at the end of the
night I didn't feel better about doing
that so I mean the issue is if I take
her back
forget about even this story of why we
broke up we fight all the time maybe
this relationship isn't meant to be
maybe it is I don't know I don't I'm
conflicted right now I miss her but
maybe it's just because I'm lonely and
maybe I need to move on yeah it's a
tough one man you know I'm not in a
relationship right now
but I'm sure that a lot of our listeners
are so I'm gonna turn this one over to
you guys you guys have thoughts or
advise is that cool with you yeah okay I
want to see what people think man
because you already kind of polarizing a
lot of you like don't you know don't
enjoy you being here and there's like I
do and but I thought it would be neat to
have already on and come and share about
some stuff that's going on I do
appreciate you sharing man I know that
yeah you know this relationships been a
crazy thing I mean this is a girl he met
after three weeks they moved in together
and I've been making love and having
living together or already has a snake
and a gun your gun owner an a yeah I
have a 12-gauge shotgun I have a pet
Rose hair tarantula yeah you know
Western hognose snake see this is the
kind of man that you're dealing with you
know and uh but yeah I'm sure a lot of
our a lot of our callers out there a lot
of our listeners will have an idea is
this just is that just a relationship
you figure it out you deal with it how
does that go if you have any thoughts
hit the hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three I'm gonna get
back to a couple more of you guys's
calls ari will you come back this week
maybe we'll do like a follow-up where we
can listen to some of the calls that
come in sure that cool yeah and then I'm
sorry you're going through this kind of
stuff
yeah it's tough man it's tough dude it's
tough you have to [ __ ] I don't know I'm
lonely so yeah yeah everyone is yeah I
don't think yeah we all yeah well human
it's human man we're humans let's keep
it human we'll be right back
I'm gonna get re out of here we'll be
right back just with the regular probe
this past weekend let's take one more
call man here we go you know Co my name
is Greg I'm gonna try to take this slow
because I'm a little slow oh it's okay
man I've been slow you know and I
probably still am slow so game
recognizes game baby boy you know I
finished college out about 270 hours of
college one degree so you do the math
dude daddy was taking his tall thank you
for calling Rick I'm 51 I just moved out
to California in January of this year
2017 welcome got out of a long
relationship 16 years of which the last
12 were without sex okay so 12 years
without sex you know that's 12 years a
jerker that's really that's a new uh you
know that's 12 years a slave to some you
know some hand activity you know but
that's okay man I appreciate you sharing
that because that's a real thing you
know that some relationship says that
that's you know it's not always a you
know a it's not always part of the
definition of of what a marriage is you
know you know composed of sex ain't
always in the recipe let's hear more so
I don't know what it means to be a man
but that part of my life didn't feel
much like a man what else yeah that can
make you feel unmanly do it even if some
of its you know if even I notice if I've
been in a relationship you know cuz I've
been in a relationship where I wasn't
even being sexual you know and that made
me feel it makes you feel like
something's wrong with you
but sometimes you're in the relationship
and it's not about you know this
relationships I've been in where it's
just about getting that don't you know
you know I'm saying hitting that wet you
know copping that still popping that you
know I'm saying hopping that crop you
know killing that canal you feel me and
sometimes it's not about that sometimes
it's about other things and then that's
just a side item you know when they take
when that side item is not on your plate
you know if you if they take the fries
off your plate or they take those greens
off your plate you still got to eat that
steak and so that's a lot of people's
marriages it seems like as you get into
it I could imagine that the day to day
is just chewing on that steak even
though you had that state you know that
steak is gonna be past or you know that
steak gonna leave their coffee company
kits and you know that steak ain't gonna
leave enough milk for you or you know
that steak gonna be furious if you can't
find their baby's shoes but that's the
steak that's the steak of it and
sometimes you stay because that's that's
your steak man that's your steak you
grilled it y'all cooking it together you
grilled it that's your steak and so you
say nice odd items got took away but you
still got the steak that you lived with
for 12 years of 12 0 12 years of steak
so I won't make any more 12 years of
slave references title movie reference
let's go maybe we got more got theatres
lots of fears a lot of regret a lot of
stuff that I hadn't accomplished in life
but I got my [ __ ] together after 28
years on the big pharmaceuticals for
antidepressants and anxiety and 16 years
on painkillers after being hit by a car
and who I'd love to know what kind of
car if you don't mind dropping that call
in or a text into the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
you're talking to a TransAm survivor
onward far off a railing I weaned myself
all that stuff on the pain meds I had my
last effexor January third still do a
little The Devil's cabbage if you know
I mean but that was with psychiatrist
and therapists blessing well then
congratulations on getting off that
effexor you know I mean I know that
those pills are powerful dude I know
that they're more powerful than us and I
don't know why they made them like that
you know why that these companies think
that we're so you know we don't have
enough will inside of us to also help
get us through the tough times but I
applaud you for that man congratulations
let's hear more they gave me the clean
bill of health
sent me on my way up to California start
things over I don't know what it means
to be a man that's what I'm trying to
figure out now I'm not in the cloud
anymore and that feels real good but I
got a thank you for talking about
feelings and said uh how you doing how
you feeling
that's what it's all about I'm feeling
good I cry a lot
cry a good stuff I like nature man I'm
doing the yoga I'm at the park in Long
Beach doing yoga on the Block six days a
week
we went from 240 to 160 Wow and I'm
gonna stop you there man and I
appreciate it
because I'm just thinking about changed
man it sounds like give a big change a
lot of changes occurred in your life and
this is feels really uh you know at 51 I
mean you sound 30 you know you sound
like the energy of a 30 man that's 30
you know you got you know to just to be
able to hear that we can change at 51 is
that's exciting you know that sounds
inspirational because I know it's harder
so now that we get older you know it's
harder we get set in our ways but one of
the biggest lies I ever heard was that a
leopard can't change his spots I don't
believe that man I don't believe that
for a second
I don't believe that whatever you're in
or whatever you're stuck in that it
can't be changed
and that's why I love this call man I
love and I appreciate you calling
because we need to hear this you know
whatever it is we're stuck in you know
sometimes you just have to get through
sometimes you know if you you committed
to a relationship you committed to
raising a child you get through
you chew that steak you get through it
but you can change it if things need to
be changed or tidied up you know you
know we try not to waste our time you
know we try not to stay on the things
that are gonna derail us you know the
pills the antidepressants you brought up
I'm on the end of the prescence man I'm
afraid to get off that's crazy because I
don't know if how I am you know I mean I
know I've suffered from depression but I
don't know if always will but now I'm
addicted to the pills I'm afraid to stop
taking them that's crazy man
you know you know we got people are
addicted to our phones you know but we
also have people we're addicted of what
realizing what's real out there you know
the friends the family the thing that
makes us feel good you know here in
somebody else's voice and not giving in
to what it becomes habitual you know
that internet it's just habitual you
know the things that are habitual you
know sitting there when your wife's
watching a TV show even though she's
just watching TV if you're to sit on
your computer that's even more isolation
already I find when you can sit there
with your wife and also watch the show
together you know do two jeopardy and
see you get some more right or do the
wheel of fortune and it's little things
like that you know that are real sure I
think that's it that's that's kind of a
good thing to do these days you can find
that common balance if you can't get
completely unhinged S connected can you
find a common balance you know can you
find enough of a balance where you get a
you know maybe there's still some
technology of all there's still
something involved but at least you guys
are both involved you know I mean I
think that's the goal these days is you
have a little just have a comfortable
balance don't get don't get to you know
back off of these things that can be
addictive you know you got to tell the
kids know to put down that mind sweep
you know to put down that whatever it is
warrior wizard or whatever it is Kat Kat
Taff any or whatever is Kat craft
because the kids will do that you know
and you got to give them a frisbee teach
them what a frisbee is you know my
nephew thought her frisbee just
something the dog get out of what the
[ __ ] no that's an instrument for joy
that's something you throw and your
little brother goes and gets and if he
doesn't go get it for you then you beat
his I ask you know that's what it was
dude that was a ghetto ass beat disc
that's what it was around my house so
sometimes you got to get these kids off
this mind sweep give him a frisbee put
them in the yard it's hot out there well
guess what it's hot as hell if you don't
live here anymore and I'll kick ass out
if you ain't willing to play in the yard
but I want to thank you guys man for
just calling in about the thoughts from
last week I've had it some couple calls
about addiction and stuff like that and
I want to drop I'm gonna drop those in
but but I you know I'm getting to it as
I can I'm excited for some of the new
stuff that we have going on
check out theof on Comm slash store I
will see you in Huntsville Alabama
coming up November 16th through the 19th
and then I will also be at Cowboys I
think that's what it's called
December 1st or December 2nd and that's
in Calgary I think is December 1st
Calgary Canada and that's all I have
right now that's what's on the calendar
so come check me out stand-up live
Huntsville November 16th through the
19th and then in Calgary December 1st
I'll put the Calgary date on my calendar
so you know exactly where that show is
thank you guys for your support and on
the way out this is Spencer Jacob growl
it's gonna take us home today and this
is his song celebrate living spencer
jacob gra you here we go
[Music]
celebrate man
have some fun while we are like
you guys be good man take care of
yourselves you probably deserve it man
thank you guys I'll uh I'll talk to you
soon
[Music]
you